el problema de tener una chispa aquí es
que a veces estos interruptores no son
mecánicos podemos construirlos con
aparatos electrónicos por ejemplo aquí
muchas veces usamos transistores y un
transistor es un aparato muy delicado y
pequeño entonces si llego aquí con una
chispa y provocó un súbito aumento de
voltaje lo más probable es que destruya
este transistor que está aquí en esta
posición funcionando como un interruptor
electrónico ahora la forma en la que
podemos lidiar con esto es encontrar un
lugar a donde se pueda ir toda esa
corriente por aquí tenemos corriente
fluyendo y el campo electromagnético
generado por el inductor está obligando
forzando a la corriente a fluir más en
esta dirección aunque movamos el
interruptor en el vídeo pasado vimos el
caso en el que tenemos un interruptor
mecánico y en este caso aquí surge una
chispa el inductor de la corriente
provoca la chispa y eso puede dañar muy
quisimos a cualquier cosa que tengamos
por aquí ahora la mejor forma de
resolver esto es con un diodo con un
diodo y los diodos son semiconductores
no son interruptores y tienen una curva
y ve de esta forma
aquí está la corriente aquí está el
voltaje y vamos a poner por aquí la
curva corriente voltaje para los diodos
cuando el voltaje es negativo la
corriente es cero y luego más o menos
por aquí la corriente sube y sube y sube
ahora cuando tenemos un diodo y este es
el símbolo de los diodos ok y este es
más y este es menos y tiene que su
voltaje y la corriente fluye por aquí
este es el símbolo de los diodos pero
bueno aquí estamos en esta parte de la
gráfica donde tenemos corriente positiva
y voltaje positivo y por cierto por aquí
tenemos puntos 6 volts puede ser punto 5
puede ser punto 8 pero cuando tenemos
voltaje
la corriente empieza a fluir a través
del río bote libremente por otro lado si
el voltaje es negativo y eso quiere
decir que en este nodo hay un voltaje
mucho mayor que en este novo si tenemos
ese voltaje negativo entonces estamos de
este lado y la corriente es básicamente
cero para el diodo o por lo menos tiene
un valor muy pequeño entonces vamos a
utilizar a este artefacto diodo para
resolver el problema que tenemos aquí y
lo que hacemos es conectar por aquí un
diodo y entonces cada que tienes por
aquí un circuito que tiene un inductor
ya sea un solenoide o un motor con los
diodos podemos proteger a todos los
componentes del circuito en donde está
la bobina o inductor así es que ahora
que ya tenemos un diodo aquí veamos qué
pasa cuando movemos este interruptor
cuando empezamos no teníamos ninguna
corriente fluyendo porque el interruptor
estaba abierto entonces no hay corriente
fluyendo por aquí
y por lo tanto tampoco hay una
diferencia de voltaje entre estos dos
puntos ambos puntos se encuentran a 3
volts no hay voltaje a través de este
diodo por lo que nos encontramos en este
punto de la gráfica toda la corriente de
0 y el voltaje a través del diodo es 0
por lo que no hay corriente aquí nada
está sucediendo y entonces movemos el
interruptor ahora si empieza a fluir la
corriente y por aquí tenemos 3 volts
entonces en este nodo tenemos más 3
volts pero por acá tenemos 0 volts así
es que tenemos 3 volts por acá del lado
que no conduce la electricidad tenemos 3
volts en la terminal negativa del diodo
por lo que el voltaje en este diodo es
negativo nos encontramos en esta parte
de la gráfica de acá me pongo por aquí
el voltaje en este nodo este es el lado
negativo positivo y aquí tenemos el
voltaje
de voltaje del diodo aquí nos referíamos
al voltaje del diodo este diodo tiene un
voltaje de menos 3 volts estamos por
aquí en menos 3 volts y como es un diodo
como tiene un voltaje negativo entonces
no fluye la corriente la corriente a
través del nodo es 0 no está sucediendo
nada por aquí toda esta corriente se va
directo a través del inductor de la
bobina para hacer lo que se supone que
tiene que hacer bueno todo funciona como
se supone que debería de funcionar pero
de repente se nos ocurre abrir el
interruptor decidimos abrir el
interruptor y lo que vimos que pasaba en
el vídeo pasado es que el voltaje aquí
se volvía muy muy muy grande de
aproximadamente
en mil volts esto es lo que sucedió en
el vídeo pasado pero en este vídeo no
vamos a dejar que eso suceda ok no vamos
a dejar que el voltaje se vuelva tan
grande en cuanto abrimos el interruptor
el voltaje en este punto suele crecer
muchísimo pero nosotros no vamos a dejar
que crezca tanto y este es el trabajo
del diodo el diodo lo que hace es que en
el momento en el que este voltaje se
vuelve 0.6 volts más grande que el
voltaje en este otro novo el momento en
el que este nodo llega a 3.6 volts
porque sabemos que el voltaje de este
nodo es de 3 volts aunque en este nodo
tenemos un voltaje de 3.6 volts en este
de 3 volts esto lo que significa es que
el voltaje del diodo es de 0.6 volts y
eso sí lo vemos en esta gráfica nos
coloca más o menos a esta altura y lo
que sucede con el día
es que en ese momento esta corriente que
estaba fluyendo por la bobina fluye
ahora por acá a través del diodo y eso
es este pedazo de la curva por acá y la
corriente va a seguir fluyendo por acá y
listo
mira lo que logramos encontramos un
camino para que fluya la corriente sin
destruir a los componentes de nuestro
circuito el máximo voltaje al que va a
llegar este nodo es el voltaje al que
llegue en esta curva y esto va a ser más
o menos entre 0.6 volts y 0.8 volts
entonces el máximo voltaje al que va a
llegar este nodo es entre 3.6 volts
y 3.8 volts y bueno generalmente los
transistores que coloquemos por aquí si
pueden soportar una diferencia de 3.8
volts entre sus dos extremos ahora a
este efecto de que de repente el voltaje
subía muchísimo les llamamos sobre
voltaje inductivo de retroceso sobre
voltaje inductivo de retroceso este es
un diodo protectivo y lo que hace es
darle una salida a la corriente inducida
cuando el voltaje aumenta más de cierta
cantidad le da otro camino a la
corriente cuando el voltaje empieza a
subir así es que es siempre que
construyas un circuito que tiene un
inductor
por ejemplo cuando construyas un
circuito que maneje un motor o un
solenoide o alguna parte de un robot
estos diodos son cosas de las que te
tienes que acordar
y tienes un inductor que vas a estar
prendiendo y apagando es una muy buena
idea diseñarlo con un diodo así para
proteger a los componentes de tu
circuito de estas corrientes
intensísimas que no se pueden detener